[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et françois-xavier
bellamy et tête de liste les
républicains pour les élections
européennes est l'invité d'auditions
publiques mon soir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation des chaînes parlementaires
du figaro et de la fp vous répondrai
dans un instant et dans un premier temps
à yves thréard et jérémy marc aux
messieurs bonsoir tout à l'heure à royal
mancini et sa verrière ojjeh quai puis
deux parlementaires viendront vous
interpeller dans une vingtaine de
minutes monsieur bel ami il s'agit de
marie pierre de la gontrie sénatrice
socialiste et pierre-alexandre anglade
député la république en marche et puis
bien sûr le chat du figaro est ouvert
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
suivent sur le site du journal vous
pouvez bien sûr poser vos questions
intervenir je me ferais votre relais sur
ce plateau ou alors françois-xavier
bellamy jeune philosophe
vous avez donc été choisie tout
récemment pour reconduire la liste et
l'air aux européennes bien sûr l'heure
n'est pas encore un premier bilan 1 ça
ne fait que commencer mais quand même
les sondages n'indiquent pas apparemment
de grands frémissement je vois entre 10
et 12 pour soi ce que vous êtes inquiet
est ce que ce chiffre vous amène à vous
poser d'ores et déjà des questions par
exemple sur votre positionnement d'abord
merci pour votre invitation
ce qui est certain c'est que quand je
suis rentré dans ces deux batailles
lorsque laurent wauquiez m'a contacté et
m'a proposé de mener cette liste je
savais très bien que ce serait dans un
contexte difficile parce que la droite
se reconstruit laurent wauquiez fait un
travail très compliqué dans un contexte
de défiance et deux défaites successives
pour notre famille politique dans lequel
il faut reconstruire et donc je sais que
cette élection européenne elle se joue
dans ce contexte compliqué et j'ai
accepté ce défi en sachant que ce
n'était pas une partie de plaisir en
roulant vous étendez fixant un objectif
si on ne l'a pas fixé à votre place
notre objectif c'est seulement de
pouvoir faire de ce moment une étape de
la refondation de la reconstruction de
la droite
et évidemment on essaiera de rassembler
le plus largement possible les français
on a pas on n'a pas faim laurent
wauquiez ne m'a pas fixé d'objectif et
si vous réussissez votre question ce qui
est certain c'est que on est dans un
moment très particulier l'histoire
politique de notre pays on aura les
raisons d'en reparler dans un moment où
on voit que les forces politiques
classiques qui ont animé la vie
politique
cependant très longtemps sont
aujourd'hui on voit d'être marginalisés
ils vous n'êtes pas pris en sandwich
justement pour ce qui est de la droite
c'est vrai de la gauche et au combien du
parti socialiste beaucoup plus que bout
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un
sandwich entre le rassemblement national
dont on voit qu'il a abandonné justement
la sortie de l'europe et qu'ils se
recentrent d'une certaine façon
et puis emmanuel macron et la république
en marche qui ont capté néanmoins on le
voit dans les sondages
une partie de votre électorat on va dire
pour faire vite l'électorat des chefs
d'entreprise l'électorat libéral c'est
difficile d'exister dans ces conditions
la leur en but ce qui est certain c'est
que nous avons quelque chose à dire de
l'europe
nous avons quelque chose à dire de
l'avenir de la france mercedes qui a
fait le coeur du projet de françois
fillon et qui on a suscité malgré tout
l'adhésion de 20% des français au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle malgré tout ce qu'on sait
de la difficulté de cette campagne
tout cela n'a pas disparu emmanuel ces
déshérités venus leur ont dit de la rue
hissant sur la liste qu'ils n'ont pas
dit ce parti nous avons si je peux me
permettre de la dureté de responsables
notre objectif c'est de tenter de leur
montrer que nous avons encore quelque
chose à dire sur l'avenir de notre pays
et que ce qui a été encore une fois
porté au cours de la présidentielle par
la droite n'est pas du tout aujourd'hui
réalisés dans l'action des manuels macro
on le voit d'ailleurs à l'occasion de
l'accueil de la vie les jeunes rang
c'est pas de l'esbrouffe mais les grands
problèmes structurels de notre pays
quels sont ils nous sommes le pays le
champion du monde en matière de
prélèvements obligatoires et c'est cela
qui fera c'est cela qui provoque la
crise sociale très profonde que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
les gilets jaunes se sont d'abord des
gens qui travaillent et qui ne s'en
sortent pas à cause de cette pression
fiscale est ce que la pression fiscale a
baissé non est ce que le coût du travail
a baissé non est ce que les prélèvements
obligatoires en baisser non est ce que
la réforme de l'état est engagée pas du
tout sur ces questionnaires ces
fraudeurs devraient venir vers vous
alors alors ce ne serait pas le cas sur
évidemment on le voit très bien les
choses vont se décanter petit à petit et
j'espère que les électeurs nous saurons
gré de n'avoir pas varié ligne
contrairement à certains dans notre
position ce sera vrai aussi sur les
questions européennes
vous l'avez dit le rassemblement
national est en train de changer de
discours opportunément à l'occasion de
ces élections si les autres partis et ce
sera peut-être le cas aussi dans marche
on le verra se met à dire la même chose
que ce que les républicains disent
depuis très longtemps à savoir que nous
avons besoin de l'europe mais que nous
avons besoin de la transformer en
profondeur
c'est peut-être parce que notre ligne
est elle a été la bonne et qu'elle est
injuste maintenant si vous me permettez
nous sommes pris en sandwich mais c'est
effectivement la difficulté de ce moment
et c'est aussi le sens de mon engagement
moi je m'engage dans cette élection
parce que je n'ai jamais cru que le
débat politique pouvait se réduire à
l'opposition du populisme et du
progressisme
c'est un clivage absurde c'est un
clivages artificiels et c'est l'image
qui prive la démocratie de l'expérience
d'un pluralisme authentique il faut
offrir un choix aux français
et c'est ce que nous allons faire dans
cette jamais mais le fait est que vous
je comprends bien votre intention mais
vous plafonné toujours à 10-12 % dans
absolument tous les sondages
est ce que on comprend pas très bien
votre positionnement pour l'instant vous
nous parler qu'à une frange minoritaire
de l'électorat est ce que vous n'avez
pas intérêt à élargir on attend un petit
peu plus sûr de vos bases
programmatiques notamment bien sûr on
est en train de terminer les derniers
arbitrages sur le projet européen vous
le savez il ya eu déjà une réunion à
menton du conseil national qui a permis
de voter
sept points fondamentaux pour la vision
que la droite doit porter sur l'avenir
de l'europe
ces sept points ils ont été l'occasion
d'un travail programmatique menée par
guillaume larrivé au cours des derniers
mois et nous sommes en train de terminer
ce travail pour pouvoir le présenter aux
français
je ne m'inquiète pas des sondages vous
savez parce que la campagne n'a pas
encore vraiment commencé que les
français n'ont pas encore l'esprit au
débat européen et que nous n'avons pas
encore eu l'occasion de faire valoir nos
propositions mais nous allons faire au
cours des prochaines semaines nous avons
déjà eu l'occasion de travailler sur la
question agricole de présenter nos
intuitions en la matière à l'occasion du
salon de l'agriculture où j'étais toute
la journée d'hier avec arnaud danjean
les années c'est vrai et on va continuer
de le faire au cours des prochaines
semaines sur l'immigration sur les vois
bien les médias dans les médias parler
sans la tutelle du parti vous avez une
image qui vous colle à la peau comme le
sparadrap du capitaine haddock pour
prendre un cliché c'est celle d'un
conservateur comment vous pouvez déchiré
cette image pas comment vous allez faire
un mois si vous en avez le désir bien
sûr le paradoxe est que j'ai publié ça
n'était pas dans la perspective des
élections j'avais arrière
en octobre dernier un livre dans lequel
j'essayais d'expliquer pourquoi le
conservatisme n'était pas en tant que
tel une option politique valable ça veut
pas dire que le temps est arrêté avec le
conservatisme
non il s'agit pas d'être immobile d'être
figée parce que nous sommes dans un
contexte de crise profonde prenons une
question toute simple la question
écologique
j'ai bien l'intention durant cette
campagne de défendre une préoccupation
écologique parce que la droite peut être
trop long
en voyez je parle librement ne s'est pas
assez préoccupée de ce sujet pourtant
majeur et que l'europe doit être en
pointe sur la question écologique
la question écologique d'une certaine
manière c'est une préoccupation
conservatrice vous me l'accorderez et de
ce point de vue là nous sommes tous un
peu conservateur s'y être conservateur
c'est considérer que ce qui compte ce
n'est pas d'abord le progrès technique à
tout prix mais que ce qui compte c'est
de savoir à quoi nous mettons alors
pourquoi nous mettons en oeuvre ce
progrès si la question qui se pose c'est
pas seulement d'être en marche mais de
savoir vers où on va alors oui en un
sens je suis conservateur mais on peut
pas être conservateur dans un moment où
tout est en train de s'effondrer sous
nos pas il faut être imaginatif il faut
être inventif pour résoudre le problème
écologique et en ce sens l'immobilisme
n'est évidemment pas une seule valeur et
vous êtes collagiste aussi donc vous
allez tenter de le démontrer parmi les
questions qui surgissent aujourd'hui
alors il ya des marches pour le climat
de la jeunesse et certains disent qu'il
faut peut-être limiter les naissances
pour ne pas épuiser la la planète
j'aimerais vous entendre là dessus qu'en
pensez vous
au fond on est ici devant un débat un
peu absurde parce que nous savons très
bien que ce qui compte ce n'est pas le
nombre d'individus qui vivent sur la
planète uniquement le nombre d'individus
qui vivent sur la planète mais la
manière dont ils vivent la manière dont
nous produisons dont nous consommons
dont nous construisons toutes ces choses
là elles font partie de ce que nous
devons réformer en profondeur et sur la
question européenne par exemple cette
année un élément fondamental aujourd'hui
nous ne pouvons plus vivre dans un monde
où on pêche du poisson en norvège
on l'emmène être traités en chine et on
le ramène en europe pour le consommer
c'est pas une question de nombre
aujourd'hui et c'est une manière de
montrer que nous sommes aussi
responsables
aujourd'hui les européens qui sont
beaucoup moins nombreux ou les
occidentaux font l'essentiel de la
catastrophe écologique par rapport à des
pays en développement qui sont beaucoup
plus nombreux et qui contribue pour une
part beaucoup plus faible par exemple à
l'empreinte carbone qui vient provoquer
le dérèglement climatique c'est on voit
bien que c'est pas une question donc
c'est une question de mode de vie et
nous avons besoin de repenser une
mondialisation dans laquelle on renonce
à ce modèle absurde qui voudrait qu'on
produise en chine
et comme en europe on fasse des services
mais qui nous permettent de faire de
l'europe de nouveau ce poumon dans l'
équilibre nouveau pour la manger avant
sur votre positionnement économique
no milk et pas seulement écologique
jérémy à une question à vous poser
justement vous connais beaucoup par
prise de position sociétal on a parlé du
mariage pour tous deux livres j'ai ça ça
infuser dans la presse on vous connaît
beaucoup moins par le prisme de vos
positions sur l'économie est ce que vous
êtes et ce que vous qualifiez de libéral
par exemple oui je pense que je pourrais
me définir comme un libéral au sens
authentique du terme ça supposerait de
bien réfléchir à la définition de ce mot
qui a été souvent galvaudée d'abord je
pense qu'on ne peut qu'être plus
libérale dans un pays comme la france ou
encore une fois nous sommes le champion
du monde des prélèvements obligatoires
il est évidemment nécessaire que l'état
et ça n'est pas être libéré de dire ça
que l'état arrête d'asphyxier les
acteurs individuels les entreprises en
les empêchant de se dévouer harriman la
cause de ce poids là vous réduisez
l'implication de l'état dans les
services publics dans l'économie
vous êtes d'accord avec ça d'abord je
pense qu'on peut faire mieux avec moins
aujourd'hui prenez la question éducative
je suis enseignant on a une éducation
nationale qui constitue le premier
budget de l'état mais qui en même temps
est l'une des plus mal classés dans
l'eau ces deux sur ses performances et
ses résultats c'est pas qu'une question
de 6,6 s'il suffisait de dépenser
beaucoup on aurait la meilleure
éducation nationale ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui on peut faire mieux avec
moins
maintenant je suis aussi libéral en ce
sens que je crois nous devons repenser
notre modèle d'aménagement du territoire
le modèle d'organiser en général ça veut
dire être pour la prééminence du marché
non justement quelle est la condition
qu'on donne au mot libéral évidemment il
faut que le marché puisse faire son
travail et un marché qui est saturée de
taxes et de charges est un marché qui
dysfonctionne mais il faut aussi et
c'est ça être libéral redonner du
pouvoir aux acteurs de terrain
redonner du pouvoir aux collectivités
locales repenser la décentralisation en
ce sens emmanuel macron n'est pas du
tout libéral cela posture jupitérienne
recentralise jacobine elle fait partie
de ce qu'ils vivent à laterrière au sein
du rpt vous allez
vous utilisez lecture et vous critiquiez
la baisse du budget de la politique
agricole commune donc c'est un peu
contradictoire ce que vous dites non
justement parce que le libéralisme
authentique celui que la philosophie
nous présente à travers la tradition
anglo saxonne celle de john locke celle
de biens en france la figure est un fils
ne sont pas du tout concentré sur la
question du marché le libéralisme
authentique consiste justement à tenter
de mettre l'état là où il doit
intervenir au bon niveau au bon endroit
et là pour le coup sûr la question
agricole c'est un cas de figure très
intéressant est-ce que l'agriculture est
un marché comme un autre
pour ma part je ne le crois pas parce
qu'il ya un enjeu il ya un enjeu de
souveraineté absolument essentiel si
nous laissons le marché faire
aujourd'hui on le voit très bien la
chine est en train de mener une
politique très agressive par exemple
d'achat des terres agricoles en afrique
mais aussi en europe d'achat de
vignobles et d'exploitation si nous
laissons le marché faire nous risquons
de perdre notre indépendance alimentaire
c'est un enjeu de souveraineté majeur et
il faut que l'état intervienne alors que
libéral peut le dire vous étiez donc au
salon de l'agriculture
hier laurent wauquiez aujourd'hui on
voudrait jamais ensemble
si bien sûr on a eu l'occasion de faire
un déplacement ensemble à belfort au
début de cette campagne on aura
l'occasion bien sûr de faire à beaucoup
de réunions publiques ensemble récit sur
scène déjà pris suffisamment soutenu
pardonnez-moi par la direction de votre
parti le fait de ne pas vous voir
ensemble on se dit mais quand est ce que
la campagne démarre est ce que la
direction de l air est impliqué dans
cette campagne
ou est-ce qu'elle a d'ores et déjà tiré
une croix sur son résultat
savez vous savez je je je m'amuse
beaucoup maintenant que je suis dans
l'action de ceux de ce jeu des
commentaires on a fait un déplacement à
belfort et le soir même tous les hits
oriali se disait la tête de liste était
tout fait par le parti et par le chef du
parti
et maintenant que laurent wauquiez
effectivement nous a donné pour mission
d'aller faire campagne et nous allons
sur le terrain et nous travaillons tous
les trois avec arnaud avec agnès qui
sont mes mais mes deux premiers
policiers ont dit laurent wauquiez se
désengage moi je ne le crois pas nous
sommes en lien régulier
évidemment cette campagne se construit
avec toutes les équipes du parti et j'ai
la grande chance d'ailleurs de pouvoir
compter sur leurs compétences et leur
professionnalisme
aujourd'hui on va évidemment travailler
avec laurent wauquiez de façon régulière
vous inquiétez pas vous aurez l'occasion
de nous on pose la question
il est mis de côté toutes les critiques
internes au parti madame pécresse par
exemple qui dit que c'est pas tout à
fait sa ligne de conduite et de penser
ce que vous défendez
c'est vrai que j'ai été vain à la fois
je reconnais qu'il était parfaitement
légitime de s'interroger sur ma
candidature qui n'avait rien d'une
évidence je suis jeune je ne suis pas
encore très connu dans le débat public
national j'arrive dans cette aventure
avec beaucoup d'humilité avec le
sentiment d'une responsabilité très
lourde il faut que je donne tout pour
pouvoir montrer que je suis au niveau de
l'enjeu et je le serai avec encore une
fois cette dimension d' équipe qui sera
très fort dans cette campagne
ce que je regrette c'est que ces
divergences se soient étalés dans les
médias je pense que malheureusement
c'est aussi ce qui contribue à l'essai
que la france malheureusement je dois le
dire c'est aussi ce qui contribue sans
doute à la défiance que beaucoup de
français ont à l'égard de la droite qui
donne le sentiment de ne pas pouvoir
dialoguer ensemble autour de ces
désaccords mais d'avoir systématiquement
besoin de les étaler ressent vraiment je
vais dans un grand pas et vous avez
raison c'est sans doute un peu le jeu on
va travailler
valence aura son mai découvrez le jeu
politique est ce que vous avez des
mentors pour vous conseiller ce que
quand on a l'occasion d'échangés très
régulièrement avec laurent wauquiez doit
et but de cette racaille maladie avec
lui qu'on sertic eu l'occasion de
rencontrer nicolas sarkozy j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer beaucoup de
figures qui comptent évidemment à droite
y compris d'ailleurs parmi ceux qui ne
pensent pas exactement la même chose que
moi ou qu'ils ne pensaient pas
d'ailleurs que je pouvais être le mieux
placé je pense à gérard larcher et bien
sûr on continuera d'échanger parce que
je n'ai jamais cru pour ma part vous
savez à l'opposition du nouveau monde et
l'ancien monde je pense pas que c'est
parce qu'on est nouveau qu'on est
forcément meilleur ce que je crois c'est
qu'il faut une complémentarité entre eux
le renouvellement nécessaire
qu'attendent les français et en même
temps l'expérience sans laquelle on ne
peut pas être efficaces gérer mais
marron vous évoquez le pot pour revenir
vous déploriez l'état l'âge de
divergences au sein de l air mais ce que
c'est plus simplement le signe de la
coexistence au sein d'un même parti de
ligne irréconciliables comme il ya eu
des gauches irréconciliables un moment
il y aurait des droites irréconciliables
actuellement le chat nerfs et je ne le
crois pas pour une raison assez simple
c'est que depuis que cette campagne a
commencé aussi bien dans le travail
qu'on a pu faire sur le projet à partir
du vote qui a été fait à menton de ces
éléments fondateurs du projet européen
qui ont été validés à l'unanimité aussi
bien dans le travail sur le projet que
dans les échanges quotidiens que nous
avons avec arnaud
en jean avec agnès et séverine je ne
sens pas de divergences profondes sur
l'avenir de l'europe nous avons une
vision partagée
bien sûr arnaud danjean vous le savez a
été juppéiste année c'est vrai n'a
travailler et travailler encore avec
valérie pécresse ça ne nous empêche pas
d'avoir une vision absolument unanime
sur ce que nous voulons défendre pour
l'avenir de l'europe
il n'y a pas de droite irréconciliables
je ne le crois pas pour ma main françois
xavier b la vie la marque décathlon
la marque de sport a mis en ligne pour
le public notamment sur son site en
français un hidjab pour les jeunes
femmes qui voulaient faire du sport ou
pas jeunes femmes d'ailleurs qu'il
voulait faire du sport en hidjab comme
accessoire qui couvre tout le visage et
qu'il est ce simplement une bande pour
que les yeux puisse boire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez d'abord il
faut rappeler que cette tenue est
aujourd'hui interdite par la loi sur la
voie publique sur la voie publique et
que soit copé le port de cette tenue
d'une dissimulation totale du visage
représente donc une infraction une
infraction pour deux raisons la première
c'est que c'est évidemment un problème
de sécurité et la deuxième c'est aussi
que se couvrir totalement le visage
contrevient profondément à notre mode de
vie
j'enseigne la philosophie et je
travaillais récemment avec mes étudiants
sur les textes de levinas qui décrivent
ce qu'est le visage dans la tradition
occidentale dans la traduction tradition
judéo-chrétienne le visage et ce par
quoi nous marquons notre ouverture à
l'autre notre vulnérabilité c'est vrai
mais en même temps notre volonté de
relation et pour ma part je suis
terrifié de voir se dessiner un monde
dans lequel il faudrait se couvrir le
visage pour pouvoir faire du sport ou
déplacer sa juste part je fais pas assez
de sport mais est-ce que vous allez
boycotter décathlon si jamais vous
fournissez chez eux
ce qui est certain c'est que je crois
que les marques ont une responsabilité
importante dans le message qu'elle
envoie à la société ce qui est certain
aussi il faut le dire c'est que
malheureusement nous ne combattrons pas
le mal par les effets mais par les
causes et la cause profonde c'est ce
modèle relativise dans lequel nous
sommes rentrés ou d'une certaine manière
nous avons renoncé à défendre ce qui
constitue notre culture commune
non pas pour exclure mais pour permettre
de rassembler autour d'elle et on se
tromperait à mon avis si on s'attaquait
uniquement aux conséquences et sur
l'éducation faut en revenir aux
fondements et effectivement la question
éducative est une question fondamentale
à vous dénoncez les marques commerciales
y en a eu d'autres avant
ils peuvent être éventuellement les
relais ou les complices d'un
communautarisme religieux
il ya effectivement une tentation
communautariste et je crois que les
marques quand elle instrumentalise sont
quelque chose de très grave je pense en
juillet à cette marque je crois mais je
ne voudrais pas la citer parce que je ne
suis pas absolument certain du nom mais
je pense à cette marque et c'était très
grave à mon sens qui avait commercialisé
une publicité montrant des enfants
voilée et le fait de voler des enfants
sur une publicité me semble être le
signe là pour le coup d'une forme de de
rupture assez assez problématique gérer
mais un tout petit mot sur le mouvement
des gilets jaunes d'ores et déjà plus de
la majorité des français demandent
l'arrêt de ce mouvement 55% agréablement
s'engage de ce matin deux tiers des
sympathisants et l'air demande l'arrêt
de ce mouvement est ce que quelle est
votre position est ce que vous aussi
vous demander l'arrêt bien sûr il faut
que ce mouvement s'arrête
c'est quand même la première fois dans
notre pays qu'on connaît qu'un semaine
consécutive de manifestations quinze
semaines de troubles à l'ordre public de
dégradation on l'a vu encore sauvé
cannes les images à clermont ferrand
sont affligeantes
je crois que d'ailleurs ce mouvement est
en train de se dégrader qu'il n'a plus
rien à voir avec la revendication
initiale qui était celle de centaines de
milliers de français qui exprimait à
travers ce mouvement leur volonté
justement d'en finir avec une pression
fiscale étouffante aujourd'hui on semble
dans une forme de purée nihilisme où il
s'agit de détruire pour détruire mais ce
qui est en jeu c'est la responsabilité
du gouvernement là dedans la mission
première d'un gouvernement c'est de
garantir la concorde entre les citoyens
et l'ordre public et aujourd'hui
malheureusement nous sommes entrés dans
une stratégie d'affrontement de
brutalisation quand sa mère lui rien à
voir avec avec cette mission il faut
qu'on réponde à cette question sur le
pouvoir d'achat et c'est la seule
manière de mettre vraiment fin à la
crise actuelle de notre pays traverse y
constate feuilles constat d'échec en
tous les cas c'est certain
merci messieurs tout de suite la
deuxième partie de l'émission mais fut
bel ami avec nos deux parlementaires
dont je vous annonçais la venue ils sont
là ils en train
bonsoir marie pierre de la gontrie vous
êtes sénatrice socialiste pierre
alexandre anglade vous êtes député la
république en marche je vais vous donner
la parole dans un instant une question
d'un internaute du figaro qui se dit
c'est très très bien de faire
connaissance avec la tête de liste et
l'air mais alors il est très choqué que
à trois mois du scrutin maintenant le
programme n'est pas encore sur la table
le programme epr et encore une fois on
en est aux dernières finalisation n'y
avait pas là donc il n'est pas là les
républicains ont été les premiers à
déterminer une ligne claire sur la
question européenne à menton c'était il
ya déjà plusieurs mois
les sept points fondamentaux de notre
projet ont été exprimées d'une manière
parfaitement clair et d'ailleurs ils ont
suscité je le rappelais l'unanimité dans
le parti s'est produit il faut du temps
entre les choses rassembler tout le
monde mais c'était une dent recoller les
morceaux
non c'était une ligne très claire et
précise qui inspire le programme qu'on
va présenter et d'une certaine manière
entre les changements de ligne du
rassemblement national et le fait qu' on
ne connaît pas encore complètement la
ligne que défendra en marche nous
n'avons pas à rougir de ce que nous
avons on en saura peut-être plus dans
les minutes qui viennent alors qu'ils
commencent madame de la contrée très
bien allez-y
bonsoir monsieur bel ami en fait je vous
regarde et on vous découvre tous puisque
vous êtes vous êtes à nouveau nouvelles
personnalités politiques et c'est vrai
vous êtes un personnage un peu comment
dire
déroutant parce que vous vous maniez des
idées vous n'êtes pas non je veux dire
qu'il n'est pas dans la langue de bois
il n'est pas dans les formules choc
alors après je ne sais pas si c'est ça
qui est adapté à la situation dans
laquelle vous avez accepté de vous
trouver
mais en tout cas c'est notable mais il
ya quelque chose sur lequel j'aurai
souhaité vous interrogez puisque c'est
possible ce soir vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises depuis le début de
l'émission notre ligne est claire nous
n'avons pas changé d'avis les français
se rendront compte
et pourtant il ya plusieurs points sur
lequel je ne comprends pas très bien
quelle est votre cohérence avec la
formation politique que vous représentez
alors il y a évidemment j'y reviendrai
puisque je crois que ça tape pas encore
été fait ce que vous avez qualifié de
votre opposition personnelle ou plutôt
votre position personnelle sur
l'opposition à liv et g
et vous vous en est expliqué c'est vrai
que ça a heurté beaucoup on pourrait
revenir si vous voulez moi ça marche
beaucoup
non je termine juste et après vous aurez
tout le loisir cette émission vous est
consacré bien c'est un petit problème
tout de même parce que votre formation
politique porte porte ce sujet et que
contrairement à ce que vous prétendez le
parlement européen a parfois se
prononcer sur ce type de sujet a dû
voter une résolution par exemple en 2002
sur le sujet donc ça pose quand même un
problème
bref mais il ya d'autres points sur
lequel vous n'êtes pas en accord avec
votre famille politique et qui sont des
points qui sont importants
vous avez dit il ya quelques temps que
vous auriez voté par exemple contre le
c'est à traiter économique entre
l'europe et le canada
vous avez dit que vous avez rappelé que
vous aviez voté non au référendum sur la
constitution européenne lors j'ai même
pas osé calculer l'âge que vous aviez à
ce moment là mais c'est dire qu'en tout
cas vous n'avez pas voté comme votre
formation politique à l'époque alors
bien on est donc ma question c'est ma
question c'est quelle est votre
cohérence avec votre famille politique
premièrement deuxièmement comment
pouvez-vous comment dire asséné que une
commande hier une opinion personnelle
pourrait prendre le pas sur des
convictions collective parce réponse
réponse et on écoute sur les deux points
alors d'abord sur la question de l'image
et si vous me le permettez et cartons ce
point rapidement parce que cette
polémique qui a été créée et est
totalement artificielle
ma seule expression a consisté à dire
que justement sur cette question nous
devrions pouvoir aussi nous mettre
d'accord pour en sortant de l'idéologie
par exemple organiser un vrai plan de
prévention qui nous permettent
d'accompagner le mieux possible toutes
les familles y compris est d'abord sans
doute celle qui sont aussi de régularité
c'est le raisonnement de tous ceux qui
ont combattu les vg de dire de dire il
faut faire de la prévention
écoutez peut-être parce que vous n'êtes
pas une femme incontestablement
peut-être parce que vous n'avez pas vécu
ce combat il faut quand même bien se
rendre compte que le problème de l' ivg
l'ibg a toujours existé la question est
de savoir si on permet aux femmes est ce
qu est ce que je hais ce que pratiquer
les ivg dans des conditions correctes ou
pas et donc être opposé
je trouve que c'est absolument terrible
unis
je n'ai jamais il ne s'est jamais agi de
remettre en cause la loi veil
encore heureux mais donc au moins ce
point est accordé une fois qu'on n'a pas
considéré non mais une fois qu'on a donc
il s'agit pas de la cause des femmes
pardon et justement prenons en charge la
cause des femmes je ne suis pas une
femme mais cette position elle est aussi
nourrie en moi voyez la première fois
que j'en parle parce que vous me poussez
par une expérience personnelle que j'ai
vécu dans laquelle j'ai pu voir à quel
point justement certaines femmes dans
mon cas c'était une amie proche pouvait
être abandonnée par le fait d'ailleurs
souvent de l'égoïsme des hommes
pouvaient être abandonné à une situation
difficile qu'elle traversait y compris à
cause d'une précarité matérielle et je
crois qu'on devrait pouvoir se mettre
d'accord c'est ce que font des
collectivités la région ile-de-france le
fait est ce que valérie pécresse et anti
ivg bien besoin qu'à l'époque la région
ile de france soutient des initiatives
qui accompagnent des femmes en
difficultés matérielles pour leur
permettre d'avoir une vraie liberté de
choix et mon seul propos consistait à
dire que si on pouvait justement sortir
des débats idéologiques pour prendre un
peu en considération de l'intérêt des
femmes les choses avanceraient peut-être
je n'ai pas mis un peu en marche pour la
vie mais c'était le sens de cette
implication
je crois que justement on devrait
pouvoir prendre en considération
vraiment à travers une politique de
prévention
cette question fondamentale maintenant
on peut être en désaccord avec moi et
considéré que la prévention ne compte
pas et considérait que ce qui suit on
peut se contenter de la situation
actuelle ça n'est pas mon cas mais je ne
crois pas à ces rites et dans votre
gueule et je suis parfaitement sincère
si je n'étais pas sincère croyez bien
que je me serais passé et d'exprimer un
sentiment sur un sujet aussi difficile
maintenant ça n'est pas très au débat
européen je le maintiens malgré tout
c'est ce sujet européen le sujet le père
n'implique pas c'est faux cette cette
question en tous les cas je ne me suis
pas exprimé sur ce sujet à l'occasion du
débat européen on a opportunément
rappelé une expression que j'avais eu un
jeune sétois sur un plateau de
télévision avait alors parlé cette
politique pourrait coûter puisque je
serai confusion les pointe et on va y
revenir dans un instant mauvais côté le
député on l'a pas entendu encore à les y
reviendra sur la question on oublie par
madame de la gontrie
merci monsieur lamy bonsoir moi je
voudrais revenir à l'europe
vous le savez la france et l'europe sont
évidemment confrontés à des défis
extrêmement importants liés à la
mondialisation contemporaine à une forme
de déstabilisation qui entourent
l'europe en sommes à la marche la façon
de la mondialisation est en train
d'évoluer
vous le savez depuis un certain nombre
d'années
votre famille politique celle des
républicains a remporté un certain
nombre de succès électoraux lors de ces
élections européennes
les républicains ont gagné les élections
européennes de 2009 en 2014
vous êtes arrivé en seconde position
avec une vingtaine de députés européens
et votre famille politique celle des
républicains appartient à une famille
politique européenne qui s'appelle le
ppe et qui depuis à peu près 2004
détient tous les pouvoirs au niveau
européen et donc moi la question que
j'aimerais vous poser c'est de savoir
pourquoi est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous vous
présentez comme la liste du renouveau ou
de la transformation de l'europe alors
que depuis quinze ans vous avez tous les
leviers de pouvoir en europe en tout cas
votre famille politique et que vous avez
été au fond incapable de préparer
l'europe ou grands changements qui sont
devant nous à la révolution numérique à
la lutte contre le changement climatique
à la régulation de l'économie
mondialisée telle qu'on la connaît en
fin de compte
serez vous capable de le faire d'abord
merci pour cette question et c'est une
joie d'échanger avec vous sur ce sur ce
sujet d'abord je crois qu'il faut être
précis pour que ceux qui nous écoutent
ne se trompe pas la droite a
effectivement enregistré des succès
électoraux au cours des dernières
élections ça ne veut pas dire qu'elle a
eu tous les pouvoirs ni que le ppe et
tue tous les pouvoirs il a eu la
majorité au parlement européen qui ne
veut pas dire et les présidences de
toutes les institutions européennes
depuis 2004 la commission barroso en mai
alors je devais qu'au niveau européen
n'appartiennent pas quand même soyons
précis les commissaires européens
n'appartiennent pas nécessairement au
ppe comme vous le savez de même que
l'inde est un style l'une des instances
fondamental de la décision en europe qui
le conseil de l'europe représente les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement prenons
par exemple la question de la baisse du
budget de la politique agricole commune
pour être très clair cette baisse de la
politique agricole commune n'a pas été
voulue par le parlement européen où par
les ppe elle a été déterminée dans une
négociation avec les états européens et
donc non c'est faux bien sûr qu en
réalité
en réalité la commission européenne
propose un budget qui est effectivement
en baisse par rapport à ce qu'était le
budget de la pac jusqu'à présent et au
lendemain de cette décision et de cette
annonce
la france le gouvernement d'edouard
philippe emmanuel macron se sont
immédiatement inscrit en faux contre ce
duguay annonçant une coalition de 19
états pour revenir dessus et donc
désormais ce sera effectivement mais
parlement et au conseil de le négocier
ne pas attendre le lendemain mais ça
c'est une autre veut dire ses talents
parlement européen et le ppe ne sont pas
les responsables de cette évolution
vous savez la décision en europe est
plus complexe que celle qui consisterait
à dire que le ppe a eu tous les pouvoirs
c'est faux deuxièmement si vous me
demandez si la droite et le ppe ont
toujours tout bien fait en europe
la réponse est non je ne suis pas là
pour vous dire que nous n'avons rien n'a
changé je ne suis pas là pour vous dire
non plus que le ppe est toujours suivi
les bonnes orientations de fait la
mondialisation évolue vous l'avez
remarqué vous même et ce qui était
pertinent dans un autre contexte mais
peut-être plus aujourd'hui si laurent
wauquiez est venu me proposer de porter
cette liste ça n'était pas pour faire
perdurer
toutes les orientations qui ont été
celles de notre famille politique au
cours des dernières années
les réorientations nécessaire dans notre
action européenne elles sont aujourd'hui
au coeur de cette prise de conscience
que la droite a eu à menton notamment en
disant à la fois que nous maintenons de
façon forte notre engagement pro
européens nous voulons d'une europe mais
nous voulons d'une europe qui puisse
nous permettre de ne plus subir notre
histoire dans la mondialisation et ça
suppose d'adapter certaines choses ça
c'est ce que dit emmanuel macron
puisqu'on annonce un grand discours ou
un grand texte dans toute la presse
européenne
une fin mars début avril sur le thème de
l'europe qui protège c'est donc lui
aussi a évolué voilà on a hâte de lire
ce discours et on a hâte de savoir
quelle sera la position dans marche
au cours de ces élections européennes
parce qu'au fond si vous voulez dans le
point de bifurcation que l'europe
connaît aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé
l'europe est à un moment important de
son histoire
nous avons à déterminer quelle est la
réorientation que nous allons lui donner
or précisément la question qui se pose
est de savoir aujourd'hui si il s'agit
d'aller vers une forme de fédéralisme
européen ce qui a été l'expression qu
emmanuel macron a voulu défendre au
cours de la du discours de la sorbonne
où dix jours d'athènes en expliquant
mais c'est tout à fait une c'est un
propos parfaitement légitime présent la
république a présenté une vision
extrêmement claires sur l'avenir lol de
l'europe ce qui n'avait pas été le cas
depuis très longtemps de notre pays ça
on peut vous avez région ne pas le
dénaturer donc c'était tout à fait
nécessaire et bienvenue parce que la
france n'a pas présenté de vision de
l'europe depuis 2005 et le fameux
référendum où les familles politiques
qui était celle du république des
républicains et du parti socialiste est
profondément fracturé sur la question et
donc n'avait plus
donc madame de la gontrie déterminer sur
ce point simplement l'année la
construction d'une souveraineté
européenne est aujourd'hui absolument
nécessaire parce qu'on se rend bien
compte que l'europe que vous défendez
celle de l'intergouvernemental isme
celle des états nations et celle en fait
de l'immobilisme et du statu quo à qui
nous sommes absolument incapables
d'avancer en europe et donc construire
la souveraineté européenne ce n'est pas
en fin de compte diluée ce qui fait
l'identité ou la singularité de la
france essaie simplement proposer une
protection supplémentaire pour répondre
aux grands défis qui sont devant nous
qui sont ceux du changement climatique
de la révolution numérique de la
régulation de l'économie du commerce
international de la défense et de la
sécurité voilà c'est là que le débat
s'engage et il est passionnant et il est
nécessaire et vous avez tout à fait
raison de le dire emmanuel macron à
proposer une vision cohérente et c'était
tout à son honneur
nous ne partageons pas cette vision ne
croyons pas pour relever ces défis il
faille aller vers une forme de
dépassement des démocraties nationales
parce que on ne construira pas une
europe efficace sans les peuples contre
la volonté populaire et les peuples
précisément c'est ce qui forme l'europe
l'europe à cette propriété d'être un
espace magnifique qui n'est ni un grand
tout impérial ni non plus une sorte de
fracturation des nations mais d'être une
alliance opposée démocratie on la
récupère grave c'est que tout ce que
vous dites tout le monde peut être
d'accord avec tout ça je veux dire c'est
des belles phrases mesquines pour leur
coût évalué le maquereau nous dit
pardonnez moi et emmanuel macron nous
dit non tu restes après marc des choses
assez assez concrète parce que quand
même vous allez être parlementaire
européen demain et les essayer vous avez
tout à fait raison et oui et donc je
reviens je reviens à ma question sur le
ceta c'est à dire vous avez déclaré que
vous auriez voté contre le c'est assez
récent 1 le bottin est d'ailleurs j'ai
noté que prudemment il avait été décidé
que la ratification ne viendrait
qu'après les élections européennes parce
que c'était sans doute trop compliqué de
le faire avant pour la france toujours
est il que vous dites que vous êtes
contre or votre groupe politique y
compris monsieur danjean qui est un des
trois candidats que nous connaissons qui
est un grand spécialiste d'ailleurs de
la question européenne
lui s'est abstenu et votre groupe a voté
pour
donc c'est là que je sois ici le
problème dit je suis que je suis je
crois que je suis très précise et je me
permets de préciser j'ai dit que je
n'aurais pas voté le sénat en l'état
c'est de fait on est assez tsé tsé tsé
la formule analogue 2 à titre personnel
c'est à dire que vous essayez projet
ménagés ce qu'on peut rentrer dans la
précision des choses justement dans le
ceta il ya des choses qui sont positives
y compris pour nos agriculteurs
mais il y avait aussi des éléments
négatifs je pense à la viande ovine vous
essayez en 2017
vous votez pour voter contre je leur ai
fait la même chose qu arnaud danjean je
crois qu'il fallait retravailler la
négociation sur le cézanne est blessé je
n'aurais pas voté le sénat en l'état pas
plus qu arnaud danjean
il n'y a pas la moindre fracture entre
sa position est la mienne voyez c'est
exact de votre mère votre pour parce que
je pense mais oui encore une fois je
suis là pour vous dire aussi que nous
avons sans doute des choses à faire
évoluer
il y avait des choses très positives
dans le ceta y compris pour beaucoup de
nos agriculteurs
il y avait aussi des choses qui posaient
de vrais problèmes je pense notamment à
la filière bovine qui n'a pas été
correctement traitées à l'intérieur de
cette négociation
et donc il me semble qu'il aurait fallu
le faire évoluer parce que nous avons
besoin d'une politique de libre
concurrence
on en revient à la question du marché
qui n'est pas seulement pour but le
commerce mais qu'ils aient pour but
d'abord la défense des intérêts de nos
propres agriculteurs de nos producteurs
qu'ils aient pour but justement de se
mettre au service des peuples et c'est
vrai que malheureusement et mai salle
c'est lié aussi à un contexte dont nous
héritons et qui se montre aujourd'hui
dépassé la politique européenne on l'a
vu dans le dossier alsthom si mince la
politique européenne de la concurrence
la politique commerciale elles ont été
construites dans une époque où on croyez
qu'on avançait vers un monde où toutes
les barrières allait se défaire on voit
bien aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas à
nous de réviser effectivement les
orientations nous devons donner à la
manière dont l'europe se construit
mais je vous promets vous ne trouverez
pas de divergence sur ce plan entre ma
famille politique
est ce que j'ai pu dire ou exprimer et
ce que j'ai pu de fait il y en a puisque
certains des amis y compris que vous
apprêtez à prendre sur les listes enfin
si j'en crois ce qui se lit dans la
presse ont voté pour
donc il ya quand même des petits
désaccords y compris avec le fait que
lorsque vous étiez encore plus jeune
vous avez voté non au référendum sur la
constitution européenne vous le
rappeliez à l'instant c'est vrai que
c'est un référendum qui a fracturé tous
les camps politiques vous avez vous le
savez également la gauche comme la
droite se sont divisés choses et nous on
n'est pas resté dans le même parti
vous vous êtes de nouveau aujourd'hui
sans la question pourquoi je salue m
pourquoi ça m'intrigue c'est que je
pense que quand on s'engage en politique
il faut qu'on ait des convictions qui
soit assez solide et qu'on arrive à les
faire vivre dans un collectif bien sûr
mais que l'on ne puisse pas en
permanence les dépasser les nier etc
et donc demain vous êtes quelqu'un de
peu connu et donc vos positions ne sont
pas connues comment les français
vont-ils s'est retrouvée sachant que sur
plusieurs points on en a évoqué
rapidement quelques uns vous êtes vous
même parfois orthogonale opposition qui
ont été défendus certains moments à
votre formation de formation puisque et
donc moi ce que je ne voudrais pas c'est
que comment dire que soit enfin ce que
je ne voudrais pas ça vous regarde pas
ça regarde votre liste mais soit c'est
un peu l'auberge espagnole ça peut vous
avez pris autour de vous disons qu'ils
pensent un peu tout et puis comme ça
tout le monde s'y retrouve
vous n'allez pas y gagner en clarté soit
c'est du cynisme c'est à dire que vous
avancez et puis de toute façon une fois
au parlement européen vous ferez par
exemple comme vous le sentez
je ne me reconnais ni dans le premier ni
dans le second risque que vous venez
d'évoquer effectivement nous avons des
histoires différentes nous avons pu
prendre par le passé les positions
différentes
il n'en il n'en reste pas moins
qu'aujourd'hui encore une fois avec
arnaud danjean avec alice semaine je ne
me sens aucune divergence sur le projet
européen vous êtes 3 aucune alors eh
bien ce sera la même chose sur la suite
de la lys nous aurons un projet très
clair et nous défendons ce projet très
clair quant à la question de savoir dans
quelle mesure nous avons à gérer les
fractures du passé s'est fracturé elles
sont réelles 2005 c'est aussi le moment
où précisément à commencer une forme de
défiance une crise très profonde du
projet européen
c'est le moment où les choses ont
commencé à aller me semble-t-il dans la
mauvaise direction je suis prêt à
l'assumer parfaitement il faut qu'on
arrive justement à repenser notre rôle
dans le projet européen et c'est ce
qu'on va tenter de faire pour ma part je
ne crois pas c'est ce qui m'avait fait
voter contre ce référendum en 2005
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse aller vers
une forme de fédéralisme il était
question par exemple d'élire un
président de l'europe le rêve des états
unis d'europe qui a été malgré tout
celui qui a évoqué emmanuel macron au
cours de ses grands discours
c'est un rêve qui se défend qui a sa
cohérence mais je ne le partage pas
alors puisque nous allons défend
alexandre anglade vous avez la parole
non mais ce n'est pas c'est pas un rêve
des états unis d'europe c'est simplement
acté du fait que dans la mondialisation
et dans le monde tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui
les nationaux avons besoin non
absolument pas au contraire moi je pense
que l'europe c'est la meilleure chance
pour sauvegarder ce qui fait la
spécificité de paris de tallinn de riga
du danemark du portugal ou de tout autre
pays je pense que si nous ne sommes pas
capables de définir collectivement les
standards les normes les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres en europe et bien ce
seront d'autres demain les chinois les
américains
peut-être un jour les sud-américains qui
eux deviendront définir les standards
qui sont bons à leurs yeux pour les
européens et à ce moment là ce qui fait
la spécificité de la france ce qui fait
la spécificité d'italie sera gommé et
donc moi je ne crois pas en une europe
qui viendraient gommer les aspérités et
les différences entre les états membres
je crois au contraire à une europe qui
vient protéger les états et qui vient
protéger la singularité de ces
différents pays
mais c'est là où le nouveau 1 c'est là
où elle vous retrouve pas parce que vous
défendez une vision de
l'intergouvernemental où on se rend bien
compte que en fin de compte la prise de
décision en europe est bloquée et
empêcher ou là où les états unis par
exemple ont mis deux années à sortir de
la crise économique et financière les
européens presque dix ans plus tard dans
sont pas tout à fait sorti pourquoi
parce que nos règles communes qui repose
principalement sur l'organisation entre
états membres nous en empêche
et donc moi je pense qu'il faut être
capable de faire évoluer ces règles les
plus frappés vous dites attention dans
la question c'est pas plus ou moins
d'europe la crise on sait qu'à l'europe
pour me construire je suis d'accord avec
vous sur le constat nous avons besoin
d'europe pour que nos pays continuent
d'exister dans la mondialisation
la question c'est de quelle europe et
prenons des choses concrètes il s'agit
pas ici de faire un discours uniquement
abstrait sur la nécessité de l'europe
prenant questions concrètes
emmanuel macron a rappelé encore
récemment son attachement au projet
d'armée européenne
et bien pour ma part je crois que c'est
typiquement la fausse bonne idée
c'est à dire à la fois un projet qui est
inefficace et incapable de faire avancer
concrètement notre volonté d'une défense
plus et plus efficiente des intérêts
européens dans le monde
aujourd'hui nous sommes en panne sur ces
questions nous achetons des drones aux
états unis les belges achètent des
avions à l'étranger au lieu de se
fournir sur le marché européen c'est un
vrai problème de souveraineté collective
un vrai problème d'autonomie stratégique
je ne crois pas au projet d'armé
européen et je ne crois pas à ça ce
projet aussi pour des raisons
démocratiques parce que et c'est très
important
on ne fera pas une europe sans la
responsabilité démocratique sans la
responsabilité des dirigeants devant
leurs populations respectives
or il n'ya pas de peuple européen il y à
une unité européenne qui se joue dans la
commune civilisation qui nous lie mais
il n'ya pas de peuple européen il ya une
diversité de langue de culture de
tradition politique et c'est ce qui fait
la richesse de l'europe et donc nous
n'avons pas et nous n'aurons pas de
débat politique commun en europe me
souvenais je ne crois pas que la
politique puisse dire carrément dû avant
sur ses moyen terme vous entendrez
régulièrement dire il n'ya pas de
démocratie au niveau européen parce
qu'il n'ya pas de peuple
p1 et moi je suis en désaccord
fondamental avec cette affirmation
et je me demande même pour solliciter un
si haut niveau est en réalité le
parlement européen un peuple le
parlement européen les traités le
stipule est une institution
supranationale et démocratique qui
représente les citoyens européens dans
leur ensemble et donc la question que je
voudrais vous posez peut-être pour
terminer à cette armée sur terminer en
quoi est-ce que vous sollicitez un
mandat européen si vous ne croyez pas à
la démocratie européenne
mais justement je pense que l'europe
peut être un espace démocratique si elle
est une alliance de démocratie ça ne
vous aura pas échappé je vais demander
une légitimité aux électeurs français
pour aller les représenter au parlement
européen je ne crois pas non plus à
l'idée de listes transnationales qui a
été porté par emmanuel macron exactement
pour la même raison
c'est encore une fois une vision qui se
défend mais nous avons une vision
alternative à proposer aux français je
suis sûr qu'elle l'ait rassemblera
largement derrière toute petite question
à payer 2 j'ai compris que vous n'aviez
pas vraiment de problème avec la
participation des amis de viktor orban
au ppe
réponse ce qui est certain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le risque et de fractures
et l'europe autour du clivage entre
populiste et progresser cet attaquant
des coteaux et se finit contre la
question est est ce que nous voulons
mettre viktor orban dans les bras de
monsieur salvini dans les bras de madame
le pen vous n'êtes pas même le probable
aujourd'hui duper personne au sein du
ppe joseph daul ni aucun membre du ppe
n'a engagé le procédure d'exclusion
contre viktor orban la situation très
actuel qui ce temps là sans doute
remettre en jeu cette question mais pour
le coup il me semble que la révolte
s'est terminée cette amère et l'accès
depuis des années on explique qu'il vaut
mieux garder à l'intérieur pour le
contrôler et qu'en réalité c'est viktor
orban qui a pris cinq ans est votre
relation elle ressemble à viktor orban
ne se seraient pas opposés à jour prend
le micro messieurs dames merci beaucoup
vous êtes merci beaucoup la fin de cet
échange merci bien faire participer tout
de suite nous accueillons au rayonnement
de chiny et sa verrière geiq qu'on la
troisième partie d'auditions publiques
[Musique]
voilà bonsoir mesdames une question d'un
un internaute du figaro c'est marie qui
dit ben voilà il ya le rassemblement
national aujourd'hui qui est revenu sur
ses positions anti européennes mais qui
veut également une réforme un peu comme
vous alors pourquoi ne pas faire
alliance avec le rassemblement national
nous demande du mari c'est la question
qui vous est posée
d'abord le débat européen est nécessaire
et sur ce plan je crois que le
rassemblement national n'a pas fait la
preuve de sa cohérence en la matière
effectivement les positions du
rassemblement national semble évoluer à
chaque à chaque élection et d'une façon
qui fait qu'il est très dense il de les
suivre
deuxièmement il ya aussi un débat
politique national et pour le coup je ne
me reconnais absolument pas dans la
vision que propose le rassemblement
national de notre vie politique
quand marine le pen m'attaque au nom du
fait que je vous présenterai une
catégorie de la population contre une
autre je crois que cette politique qui
veut fracturé la société française elle
va exactement cela
votre vérité je n'ai pas de contact avec
marion maréchal encore une fois ce jeu
non seulement vous attaquent pas mais
elle est plutôt ravi de votre
candidature pensant que ça va faciliter
les alliances elle se trompe moi j'ai
toujours été parfaitement clair sur le
sujet j'ai publié un texte dans le
figaro d'ailleurs il ya quelques mois
pour dire à quel point il me semble que
nous pouvons avoir la certitude que le
rassemblement national n'est pas notre
avenir il est on le voit bien d'ailleurs
dans ce clivage entre populiste et
progressistes qui d'une certaine manière
fait système la question est que les
deux semblent empêcher toute véritable
alternative à l'intérieur de notre vie
démocratique
je ne crois pas du tout que dans la
crise que nous traversons et de place
pour une alliance de boutiques comme une
forme de remède à cette crise et je le
crois d'autant moins que comme je vous
le disais à l'instant je ne me sens pas
de points communs avec la vision de la
société qui est proposée par le
rassemblement national
nous avons besoin d'une politique
courageuse lucide ferme cohérente mais
nous avons besoin d'une politique qui
rassemble les français au lieu de les
diviser
et ceci fait une différence majeure
précisément la grande différence pour
vous entre la droite et l'extrême droite
entre les républicains et le
rassemblement national c'est quoi si
vous vous dites là je ne serais pas la
passerelle entre la droite et l'extrême
droite
quelle est la principale différence
c'est comme quand j'entends jordan
bardella à l'occasion de son premier
discours d'hier il faut arrêter de faire
des cadeaux aux riches avec l'argent des
pauvres
j'ai l'impression d'entendre georges
marchais et je ne me sens aucun point
commun avec cette perspective là le
rassemblement national et étatiste il
est d'une certaine manière en dans une
dans une vision de la société qui
ressemble à celle de la lutte des
classes ça n'a rien à voir avec la
perspective que je voudrais pour mon
pays parce que je crois que nous avons
besoin de rassembler les français on a
beaucoup parlé d'europe sur les flux
migratoires justement par exemple est ce
que votre discours les discours des
républicains si éloigné que cela que de
celui de marine le pen c'est un exemple
très intéressant parce que voyez on fait
on parlait tout à l'heure de question de
vision européenne mais il faut que ça
sent carrément des choses concrètes sur
la question migratoire
je ne crois pas du tout moi pour ma part
que nous puissions dans une forme de
repli national trouver la solution au
problème migratoire monsieur salvini a
fait une politique très très très ferme
sur la question met instantanément les
flux se déplace vers l'espagne et donc
on voit bien que si nous ne savons pas
travailler ensemble en europe ne
pourront pas construire une politique
migratoire efficace
or le défi est devant nous
donc nous devons travailler ensemble la
solution elle passe par l'europe et
c'est ce qui nous distingue évidemment
profondément du rassemblement national
qui même si la position du rassemblement
national évolué est clairement
aujourd'hui encore dans l'idée qu'il
faut comme le dit marine le pen faire
sauter le bunker de bruxelles nous nous
croyons à l'europe mais nous croyons
aussi et c'est ce qui nous distingue des
manuels macron à la souveraineté des
peuples francs des peuples d'europe et
nous croyons par conséquent nous n'avons
pas le droit de renoncer à une politique
migratoire démocratique qui soit donc
l'effet de notre propre décision
nous voulons donc d'une certaine manière
une double protection nous voulons
travailler ensemble à défendre les
frontières extérieures de l'europe et
nous voulons pouvoir poursuivre la
dérogation qui existent actuellement à
la circulation dans l'espace schengen
qui est utilisée parce que la crise
terroriste la plus imposés nous voulons
pouvoir l'a prolongé y compris pour
faire face à la question des grattoirs
d'une manière durable de cette façon là
les français seront mieux protégés que
s'il votait y compris pour le
rassemblement national il ya de grands
rassemblements en ce moment en algérie
contre un nouveau mandat de bouteflika
est ce que cela vous inspire
de l'espoir ou world des craintes en
matière justement d'immigration éventuel
un espoir et une crainte l'espoir de
voir évidemment l'algérie construire une
une démocratie qui associe mieux en
particulier sa jeunesse et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui c'est cette jeunesse qui
se révoltent une crainte évidemment
majeur parce que si la situation
dégénère en algérie et se dégrade
profondément
nous savons très bien que par les liens
que nous avons avec ce pays nous serons
pour gagner que directement en lien
comment craignait qu'elle dégénère
aujourd'hui ce qui est sûr est dans le
pré mais lloris lance une mise en garde
aux algériens contre les risques de
dérapage sérieux lors des manifestations
ce qui est certain c'est que ces
manifestations elles sont l'expression
d'une colère qui déborde aujourd'hui le
champ institutionnel
or ce n'est jamais bon de voir que les
institutions ne sont pas capables de
canaliser la colère parce que c'est le
signe d'une tension qui risquent de se
transformer en violence
c'est un nouveau contrat en france début
d'un nouveau printemps arabe
il est il est très tôt pour le dire il
est trop tôt pour le dire il y avait
entre 800 mille et un million de
personnes dans les rues
vendredi dernier aujourd'hui nous sommes
devant des manifestations qui sont
parfaitement pacifique qui sont
paisibles
il faut qu'elles se poursuivent dans ce
climat je crois il faut que les jeunes
algériens puissent manifester leurs
aspirations il faut que cette aspiration
surtout puisse se traduire de façon
encore une fois paisible dans le cadre
des institutions nous dans tous les cas
ce qui est certain c'est que toute
dégradation de la situation serait
préoccupante pour la france évidemment
parce que l'on appelle dans ils ont déjà
ce désir parce que nous avons bien très
très spécifique avec le peuple algérien
par notre histoire par les liens qui
existent entre nous et que nous savons
très bien que nous nous ne sommes pas
nous ne pouvons pas nous considérer
comme étant totalement indifférents ou
alors le risque si je comprends bien ce
serait une vague migratoire vers la
france bien sûr potentiellement avec
tout ce que ça implique aussi de
difficultés dans un pays comme la france
qui lui aussi a ses propres ses propres
tension à gérer aujourd'hui et je crois
que ce serait bien sûr il ya une source
de préoccupation à votre vision de
l'europe et notamment la question des
nations vous en avez un petit peu parlé
mais est ce que pour être clair le
message que vous voulez porter c'est
aujourd'hui l'union européenne ce n'est
pas la disparition des nations mais leur
défense
le message qu'on voudrait porter c'est
que l'union européenne elle doit être
efficace au service des peuples
européens et que c'est en faisant la
preuve de cette efficacité que nous
pouvons retrouver toute la valeur de
l'idéal européen et sur beaucoup de
sujets encore une fois qu'ils sont très
concrets on parlait de la politique
agricole commune par exemple on a passé
hier la journée avec avec christian
jacob avec agnès evren et arnaud danjean
au salon de l'agriculture
l'europe doit faire la preuve de son
efficacité alors que trop souvent
parfois aujourd'hui elle donne le
sentiment de nous entendre sur cette
question de nation parce que c'est un
terme important chez vous et vous avez
dit dans une interview il est incroyable
qu'on ait réussi à faire de l'idée de
nation unie des coupables
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous définissez
comme un nationaliste ce que je trouve
étonnant c'est qu'effectivement dans le
mot nationaliste il soit aujourd'hui
impliqué une idée de culpabilité une
idée de fautes
au fond la nation c'est le cadre dans
lequel s'effectue la vie démocratique de
notre pays dans lequel s'effectue la vie
démocratique en europe
l'europe a inventé à travers le modèle
de la cité grecque est aujourd'hui à
travers le modèle des nations ce cadre
efficient pour vivre le nationaliste
n'est pas un gros mot vous pourriez vous
définir comme nationaliste mais je suis
profondément attaché à la nation est
profondément attaché à la france
évidemment et je pense que si la vie
politique a un sens et celle de ce lien
commun qui existe entre nous de ce
plébiscite de chaque jour d'en parler
renan qui est justement ce qu'on appelle
une nation avoue regretter un peu
l'usagé qui est fait aujourd'hui de ce
mot nationalisme et vous ne l'utilisez
pas pour vous même vous restez sur vos
gardes
c'est dire qu'au fond ce que je veux ce
que je déplore et que je constate c'est
que ce mot soit entachée d'une telle
connotation négative qu'il soit devenu
difficile de l'utiliser
est ce qu'être et nationalistes ça veut
dire détester les autres nations parce
que c'est souvent l'idée qu'on se fait
de ça moi je ne crois pas qu aimer sa
nation soit haïr les autres et je ne
crois pas de la même manière que d aimer
sa famille d'une manière un peu
singulière soit détesté toutes les
autres familles ce serait ridicule de
penser que pour aimer son pays on a
besoin de considérer qu'il est
supérieure à tous les autres et ce qui
est vrai c'est que les nationalismes ont
fait beaucoup de mal à l'histoire de
l'europe et on peut comprendre cela
on peut comprendre ce passif d'une
certaine manière mais nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui non pas de nier le cadre
national mais de retrouver une forme de
briques libre dans la construction
beaucoup de citations à romain gary
mitterrand qui avait dit que le
nationalisme c'est la guerre oui bien
précisément jeu c'est vrai que je
m'inscris en faux contre ces pass
perspectives quant à la citation de
romain gary qui oppose le patriotisme
nationalisme vous le savez oui c'est une
manière de
pour romain gary de dénoncer de façon
spécifique une certaine définition de la
nation romain gary est un grand lecteur
d'une tradition philosophique que celle
de herder par exemple qui a conduit
c'est vrai à ce gigantesque désastre du
20e siècle et on peut comprendre dans sa
bouche cette opposition mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui elle n'a pas tellement de
signification et que nous devrions
pouvoir réapprendra rejouera et mais
humblement et simplement chacun de nos
pays aujourd'hui s'opposer ou les
parties daddy nationalistes sont un
petit peu à la pointe
du combat en europe au les partis
populistes est ce que selon vous le
premier danger qui menace l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est une percée populistes
et nationalistes aux élections
européennes ont trois mois exactement le
grand danger qui menace l'europe c'est
celui vous avez raison d'un repli
nationaliste d'un repli national celui
qui viendrait faire s'effondrer le
projet européen et c'est un ange est
gigantesque parce que dans le contexte
de la mondialisation nous avons plus que
jamais besoin de travailler tous
ensemble nations européennes est à
européen peuples européens pour pouvoir
renforcer
chacun de nos peuples dans sa démocratie
c'est-à-dire dans sa capacité à décider
de son destin
saverio françois-xavier bellamy trop
engagé trop clivant trop catholique
archaïque c'est ce qu'on entend sur vous
au sein même de votre propre famille
politique soit quel projet européen vous
comptez réconcilier cette famille
réconcilier les électeurs de droite que
les projets europe 1 qui va tous vous
réunir d'abord ce projet européen il me
précède ce ne sera pas celui de français
xavier bellamy et celui de dire on a
encore une fois on fait cette objection
c'est lourd aux républicains mais entre
le rassemblement national qui change de
programme à chaque élection et et bien
sûr parce que je veux dire je le répète
une nouvelle fois nous avons fondé à
menton les sept points fondateur de
notre projet européen ils sont clairs
ils sont précis nous sommes résolument
en faveur de la poursuite de la
construction européenne nous voulons
transformer la manière dont elle se fait
nous refusons l'élargissement ce qui
fait une différence majeure avec
emmanuel macron tout c'est tous ces
éléments structurants ils sont
aujourd'hui acté et il rassemble
largement toute la famille politique
maintenant c'est vrai que peut-être pour
sortir de ces clichés que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure j'assume tous mes
engagements mais je ne voudrais pas
qu'on me prête ce que je n'ai pas dire
ce que je n'ai pas fait pour aller plus
loin je voudrais essayer de revenir à ce
qui a fait le coeur de mon engagement
personnel je suis enseignant je pense
que nous avons besoin de défendre une
europe de la culture je pense que nous
avons besoin de défendre une europe du
patrimoine une europe qui ça justement
valorisé ce qui a été construit par ceux
qui nous ont précédés pour nous projeter
dans l'avenir pour jouer aussi la carte
de notre patrimoine et de notre culture
au sein de deux
dudu contexte touristique qui se dessine
mais plus largement pour pouvoir ont
parlé tout à l'heure de la question du
diable lutter contre les
communautarismes il faut savoir dire qui
nous sommes c'est à dire aussi savoir
préserver notre héritage il transmettre
voilà ce qui a fait mon engagement
fondamental puis je pense aussi à la
question de l'écologie qui est une
question majeure est que j'essaierai de
porter au cours de ce débat avec tous
ceux qui m'accompagnent on va se
projeter dans l'avenir un avenir proche
le soir du 26 mai est ce que laurent
wauquiez sera comptable de votre corps
ou est ce que vous demande vos en
assumerait seul la responsabilité ni
l'un ni l'autre la reconstruction de la
droite c'est une histoire qui va prendre
du temps bien sûr ce qui me lisent
évidemment je j'assume en prenant la
tête de cette liste la responsabilité du
score que nous ferons tous ensemble je
l'assumerai aussi avec toute une famille
politique et je crois que donc le rang
ce qui est notable
on le sera tous mais on le sera tous y
compris ceux qui malheureusement ont pu
parfois joué un peu le jeu de la
division jeu je le regrette parce que je
crois que c'est une manière je le disais
tout à l'heure beaucoup se sont exprimés
dans les médias je comprends les
réserves qui ont pu être exprimés je
pense que si nous ne savons pas
aujourd'hui nous rassemble et nous
serons effectivement responsable des
difficultés des réserves sur votre
candidature y compris gérard larcher par
exemple le président du sénat est ce
qu'aujourd'hui ces réticences sont
derrière vous serrez verdi et je l'en
remercie qu'il qu'il allait soutenir
cette liste qu'il allait voter pour elle
gérard larcher vous savez si c'était
l'opposant qu'on dit je serais rassurée
parce que il a eu l'occasion de dire à
quel point il avait de l'estimé pour ce
que j'avais pu faire il pensait qu'il
fallait que je sois sur la liste en
position éligible il pensait que j'étais
peut-être pas le mieux placé pour être
en tête de liste et je peux comprendre
ses réserves
maintenant que nous sommes en crise dans
la campagne il faut que tout le monde se
rassemble sinon encore une fois c'est
vrai que nous serons solidairement
comptable de la difficulté niveau depuis
le début de votre entrée en campagne en
fait c'est quoi cette date verser des
tatas d'affronter les gens qui sont non
pas vos adversaires politiques mais vous
vous censé être vos amis non le plus
difficile je vais vous dire est ce qui
m'a le plus étonné c'est que si je ne
m'étais connu que par la description qui
a été donné deux mois à travers certains
médias au cours des premières semaines
de cette campagne je pense que je ne me
serais pas reconnu et que même je me
serais détester à je je je ressemble à
une espèce de
vous l'avez dit d'ayatollahs trop
catholique j'ai toujours par exemple
malgré oui mais je ne voudrais pas leur
procès surtout que ces critiques venait
de votre famille politique ne sont pas
totalement de l'extérieur mais je vous
feriez détestera eu oui je pense je me
suis engagé en politique justement avec
le souci je suis enseignant en
philosophie avec le souci d'entrer dans
le débat toujours du point de vue de la
raison de la raison commune et d'une
délibération intelligente et
respectueuse
dans tous les cas qu'ils fassent
l'effort de l'intelligence collective et
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'image qui a
été donnée le mot au cours des dernières
semaines
la ville a mis le 16 mars vous
dévoilerez votre projet et votre liste
complète est ce que vous nous confirmer
que nadine morano
rachida dati brice hortefeux en première
partie parce que tout ça c'est pas très
nouveau monde et je ne peux rien vous
confirmer parce que c'est une liste qui
ne sera pas à le fait de ma décision
mais de la commission nationale
d'investiture qui va se réunir dans les
prochains jours donnez pas votre mot à
dire sur votre liste
si j'ai certainement un mot à dire sur
la liste moi ce que j'ai un autre ce que
j'ai dit dès le début si vous voulez dès
le début de cette aventure quand on m'a
proposé de figurer sur cette liste
j'ai dit que pour ma part il me semblait
que pour que ce soit utile il fallait
que je ne sois pas le seul à incarner le
renouvellement
je n'ai jamais cru à l'opposition de
l'ancien et du nouveau monde mais je
crois qu'il faut que le renouvellement
que la droite à temps soit au delà de sa
simple personne et la commission
d'investiture qui a voté notre
investiture à voter dès sa première
réunion le principe de 50 % de nouveaux
noms dans les vingt premiers noms de la
liste
donc rassurez vous ce que vous durera
d'été que ces trois noms ce soit sur
votre liste
encore une fois je voulais money c'est
tout simple je pense qu'il faut du
renouvellement il faut aussi de
l'expérience et il faut c'est très
important se souvenir que ce n'est pas
la liste de françois xavier bellamy mais
celle du parti ni aller piocher quelques
regrets avec la commission avec la
présence de ceux qui par et elles sont
baptisées dans votre partie des vieux
schnock sais que vous les appelez en
privé en fait je voudrais que la liste
ressemble exactement à ce trio qui a été
investie chute en vue d'avoir été
investis avec arnaud danjean et agnès
evren agnès et moi nous sommes nouveaux
arnaud lui vient de faire deux mandats
au parlement européen je pense et cette
complémentarité qui pourrait être
efficace au service des français
une question d'actualité non justesse
que sur votre liste qu'il y aura que des
politiques où il y aura également des
gens de la société civile des
intellectuels ou autre vous voyez je
suis là pour en témoigner
ainsi aussi évidemment une place qui
sera faite à la société civile sur cette
liste bien sûr la question d'actualité
savait rien on a appris tout à l'heure
par la bouche du président américain que
13 djihadiste français
treize français vont être jugés en irak
qu'ils avaient été arrêtés en syrie
est ce que le fait qu'il soit jugé en
irak ça correspond à ce que vous
souhaitez bien sûr je crois que c'est
nécessaire d'une part parce que
aujourd'hui nous le savons en france
nous n'aurions pas les moyens pour la
plupart d'entre eux de matérialiser les
faits qui leur sont reprochés
et comme nous sommes un état de droit
qui s'honore de nous condamner les
personnes que lorsque nous avons des
preuves il aurait été très difficile de
les condamner pour les faute qu'ils ont
commise françois-xavier bellamy est ce
que tous les djihadistes arrêtés en
syrie
c'est treize personnes c'est très
français ont été arrêtés ans et doivent
être jugés en irak
je pense qu'elles doivent être jugés là
où elles ont ou au plus proche des
territoires où elles ont commis des
crimes de guerre où elles ont été
associés à des crimes de guerre parce
que sinon encore une fois en france nous
n'aurons pas les moyens de procéder à
leur jugement et de judiciariser la
situation donc pour être clair vous êtes
contre le retour des combattants parti
faire le djihad au levant pour adrien
cher puisqu'on nous annonce la
possibilité puisqu'ils vont être libérés
des prisons cup
on nous parle de l'option d'un cas
étudiés au plus haut sommet de l'état de
leur retour là votre position la
position que les républicains défendent
c'est aussi la mienne est parfaitement
clair il y aurait un grand danger à voir
revenir sur le sol français ces
personnes nous pouvons procéder
exactement comme l'ont fait par exemple
nos amis de grande-bretagne considérer
que ceux qui ont voulu brûler leurs
passeports en quittant le territoire
français pour engager le combat contre
leur propre pays doivent être jugés là
où ils ont commis leur crime
sinon encore une fois nous n'aurons pas
les moyens de les juger et nous savons
que nous allons devoir les relâcher dans
la nature sur le sol français où ils
représenteront évidemment une menace et
un danger
dernière question rien à un dernier mot
kanak n'a rien à voir pour retour à
votre famille politique bruno retailleau
il a défendu votre candidature il a la
même vision que vous c'est à dire que la
reconquête la reconstruction la droite
elle doit passer d'abord par les idées
est-ce qu'il ferait un bon leader pour
votre famille politique
bruno retailleau joue un rôle très
important effectivement vous l'avais dit
au sein de notre famille politique parce
que j'échoue et donc est ce qu'il fera
bon patron de partie c'est ça la
question le patron du bar qui est
laurent wauquiez il a été élu par les
militants une très large très large
majorité vous me demandiez si il était
responsable des résultats que nous
ferons il est le patron du parti il est
responsable de gérer ce parti au cours
des prochaines années
il lui faudra du temps bien sûr pour
mener à bien cette mission difficile de
refondation de la droite mais dans cette
mission c'est une chance qu'il puisse
compter sur le soutien et sur l'aide et
sur l'appui d'une figure comme celle de
bruno retailleau qui est une figure très
importante bien sûr parce qu'il apporte
aussi ce travail des idées qui me semble
effectivement nécessaire dernière
question toute dernière françois xavier
belloumi est ce que vous saviez vous
avez conclu votre deal avec votre
banquier vous voyez ah oui problème
je suis désolé d'ailleurs parce que il
ya eu évidemment une incompréhension non
on est en train d'y travailler
il ya aucune n'y a aucune inquiétude à
avoir
j'ai été investi le 29 janvier et des
confrères vos confrères se sont étonnés
de trois semaines plus tard que je n'ai
pas encore pu trouver un emprunt le
salut pour tous les français savent que
ça prend du temps de souscrire un
emprunt de plusieurs millions d'euros
on y travaille avec toutes les équipes
du parti qui font un travail remarquable
et finira pas aucune inquiétude
cette campagne sera financée pas signer
encore en fait c'est pas si ni engrais
verts votera bien quand même à l'emploi
paraît-il pour l'alléger l'objet de cet
emprunt alain très bien merci à vous
merci on ne porte qu'une merci merci
merci et la semaine prochaine c'est eric
woerth le président de la commission des
finances et l'eire qui sera notre invité
qui n'a pas toujours eu des mots très
aimable à votre endroit vous avez rien à
dire son sujet non il est gouverneur
quelqu'un comme important au sein de
notre parti
merci à vous merci à tous et la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]